trevor rogers on the bump for the
marlins tonight the nl rookie of the
month
numbers back him up
through six starts this season he's been
outstanding
colton wong a couple of home runs missed
some time this year with an oblique
injury
waved at miss there's a look at the
change up one strikeout for rogers just
about
another strikeout on the changeup for
trevor rogers he's got two
yeah let's give you another look at this
outstanding change up
arm side away
from kane
same sequencing that you saw against
wong
baseball's version of the hurry up
offense look at the numbers four suitor
partner yeah first start for him he
pitched a couple of days ago against the
phillies one inning bottom of the first
inning two outs runner in scoring
position and adam duvall
coming up
lined and that's going to get into left
field to base it
adam duvall scorched another one
and it brings up miguel rojas a
one-nothing marlins lead
all right i'll rant and rave about the
extra base hits but certainly will take
the exit velocity in the two out hit any
way you get it especially when it drives
in a run
to be activated very good news for the
brewers
ground ball and that's a fair ball
hugging the third baseline and into left
field
nottingham rounds first he is chugging
into second with a stand-up leadoff
double here in the top of the third
inning
so nottingham continuing to swing it
well
since reuniting with the crew
and it hit fair right behind the third
base bag and then was down into the
corner and it was extra bases from that
moment on
the pitch over and strike three called
on kane
fourth strikeout for trevor rogers
he freezes him with a fast ball away he
was going in and in you're thinking that
it's going to be a change up away
because that's what he's been doing the
whole game so far and he just freezes
him with just the fastball right on the
outside corner
well he just finished pulling that
fastball i would not be surprised if you
see a change up away on this pitch
pitch is swung on and missed
it was a fastball in
and
that might have surprised the hitter
taylor he goes down on strikes and a
terrific job of
managing this inning
i didn't really think he was gonna get a
seven inning outing today miggy on his
way to third lorenzo kane comes up
throwing and it's a little late a single
for garrett cooper and the marlins have
him on the corners with one out
a good swing by coop clean base hit up
the middle rojas
testing
the arm of lorenzo kane
just enough to get it back through the
middle and there goes rojas with no
hesitation
a good throw by kane maybe
a couple of feet
off its mark
i love the aggressiveness thinking
third the entire time
one-nothing marlins lead golden
opportunity here bases loaded one out
for issan diaz and diaz with a drive
right center field and it is gone the
grand slam is
nissan has found that stroke i could not
be happier for this young man all right
i was telling you before the game today
there's one guy in this lineup
lefty lefty that i believe in him i
think this kid has found the stroke that
this is sustainable
this is the guy that we're going to see
a little bit more of as this year
continues to move on and once again
diaz
stepped into the moment
comes up with his best swing
and does it in grand fashion
now no waiting around
jumps on the express
deep fly ball to right center field
i remember dale swame had a hole in one
on an off day
i saw it with my own two eyes
pop up right field cooper got a long way
to go and he drops it he went to a slide
and that's her why and in the second
base urias let's see how they score that
one that should have been caught that
was up in the air a long time cooper
i think he just stays on his feet he's
able to make the catch easily yep upset
with himself he knew he made a mistake
said man i should be playing first base
right now big spot here for pablo reyes
and reyes hits a bullet into left center
field to base in
duvall will play it back to the infield
they're going to wave uris and he will
score throw gets away
man that is a risky send by jason lane
yes it was but urea scores the run the
brewers have one on the board in this
fourth inning a pretty good relay throw
right there from rojas they nearly got
him
jason lane down by five runs
a little risky just trying to get
something going put something on the
board
out there in the fourth inning here's
the next one and a ball lined toward the
gap in right center another hit for
miguel rojas center fielder tried to cut
it off and booted it but there's no
further damage done it's a double for
miguel rojas his second hit of this game
and that's his ninth
two base hit he leads the club and
doubles two balls and a strike the
pitcher checks the runner and a ground
ball base hit
just inside the bag at third down the
left field line into the quarter
miguel rojas comes on to score a 6-1
lead for the marlins on an rbi double by
jesus aguilar
who was dying for a hit
he definitely was and this time he
finally got that foot down got that foot
down early was able to catch up to that
fastball and rips it down the third base
slide
to left duval dives and he got it what a
play out of
duvall what a play
well hats off to you adam duvall and
well hats off to you partner
you called it before the third base
umpire did that's who i was looking at
and you got way out in front of this one
producer saying move on there's a base
hit back up the middle
and duval around third on his way to the
plate kane's throw is close
and not again saying he got him
duvall did not slide not again is
convinced he got a tag on him pat murphy
bench coach
and they're gonna check it out that five
he posted that means the most likely
scenario
that he is out oh yeah got him on the
foot bitty i think you got him on the
back heel yeah that's a heck of a play
right there by jacob nottingham this
will be a pretty good look at it
yeah he got him on the pant leg it
looked like his pant leg moved brushed
him he's
[Applause]
win